l'affairé nous allons maintenant parler
de cinéma on reste quasiment dans le
sujet puisqu'on vient de voir sophia
loren et votre avis jeanne moreau nous
allons parler de maladie d'amour c'est
un film signé de jacques deray avec
nastassja kinski jean hugues anglade et
michel piccoli scénario danièle thompson
sorti aujourd'hui à 14 heures c'est à
dire dans une demi heure l'histoire je
vous situe en gros le l'histoire de ce
film une jeune femme nastassja kinski
deux hommes qui n'ont pas tout à fait le
même âge
on l'a ainsi vous vous êtes un éminent
cancérologue de bordeaux vous aimez
cette jeune femme clémence et un interne
dans votre service promis à un bel
avenir il aime aussi cette jeune femme
vous avez l'un et l'autre des rapports
que l'on pourrait qualifier de comment
entre vous et ce jeune garçon a très
bonne question parce que vous voulez de
résumé de l'histoire du film donc
l'histoire d'une dame et deux messieurs
oui mais une histoire d'une dames et
deux messieurs c'est toujours beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'on n'ose l'imaginer
dans les rapports entre le perçage
jungle comme l'un des miens c'est qu'il
ya un rapport de séduction en tout bien
tout honneur comme on dit c'est un jeune
interne qui a un avenir brillant vous
patrick tellement il me plaît
intellectuellement nous nous plaisons
donc c'est une j'ai le pouvoir aussi
dangereux n'a pas le pouvoir et je dois
dire qu'il y a une c'est une histoire
entre trois couples finalement il ya le
couple louis les acquis anglade kinski
piccoli et anglade piccoli très bien
qu'il ya une dames et deux messieurs les
deux messieurs faut toujours un couple
infernal aussi et ils sont liés par
cette maladie d'amour car ils en sont
atteints tous les trois de cette maladie
d'amour il faut y ajouter la maladie de
la jeune fille oui c'est à dire que nous
nous débattons d'un 2-2 thème terrible
comment sauver une personne qui est
atteinte physiquement elle est comment
la sauver dans sa vie aussi quand on est
fou amoureux passionnés on va là et
qu'on se l'arrachent alors nous allons
voir quelques images vous avez enfin
pardon et à la fin il dit à anglade
écoute
malheur toutes ces radios la médecine
scène le clown à dire si nice l'aude
maladie d'amour mais l'idée à moukalla
pour toi je te la laisse à la voyant
l'extrême maintenant c'est le petit
déjeuner entre vous et et nastassja
kinski regardons enfin qu'est-ce qui
boudent don et betty site web ou non je
dis tu sais quoi encore
je n'essaie de la maison
je vous la trouvez exactement tout
visage connu alors si je lis bien le
critique du figaro ce matin y en a
d'autres mais alors lui allé voir
maladie d'amour pour applaudir michel
piccoli dans la puissance de séduction
fait de sobriété d'autorité ébranlée par
le désarroi et c'est alors là vous avez
été mieux que jamais d'après ce
journaliste je voudrais vous parler de
vos rapports avec ces deux jeunes
comédiens c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
facile de tourner avec deux jeunes
comédiens qui a autant de talent je
dirais lorsque cette jeune femme a l'air
tout à fait étonnant la manière dont
elle parle à milan qui joue ses yeux son
regard nécessaire qu'une esquisse est
une sorte de pur sang mais pas loin des
courses vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
pur sang est belle c'est un pur sang
pourquoi l'avez vous comparez un romy
schneider
parce que là la fébrilité le l'émotion
la la quiétude de touques avec amy
reines de stars non pardon aux graines
de stars graines de merenda tatchou
alors une dernière chose à me dit que
vous aviez joué en jouant dans ce film
contre les personnages qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça j'ai lu ça que vous aviez
décoder vous aviez inventé et vous aviez
joué parfois contre entre guillemets les
personnages pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
très typés très codé parce que jacques
deray - actuellement et jacques deray
aussi nous aimons énormément l'ambiguïté
et les abysses chez les individus alors
quelquefois il faut dire le mot
contraire que qu'on n'ose pas dire après
ça ne travailler avec vous et avec deux
en même temps là haut je compte fait
vous comprendre je crois qu'on a très
bien que je peux pas lui est déjà
difficile où on a très bien travaillé
très belle renée tai coûté 6,1 juge si
j'en juge par don par mon confrère des
figaros bas il est plutôt content cela
dit j'ai eu d'engueulade c'est aussi une
sorte de pulsion on est un garçon
prenant
c'est d'un très bon vous savez entre les
pur-sang entier mais pour cent du mans
vous aviez laissées à pirey de braise
peut-être vous pourrez voir les chevaux
le sénat passion oui mais vous verrez
après le journal qui compte bien donner
rendez vous